c'mon Aronian tied for first now at the
Ziegfeld Cup with a stunning display
well play true gangster just what he
needed to sacrificing on a seven and
going for it
LaVon this position certainly was a
flame after you took on f7 you certainly
couldn't have seen all the variations
that could have transpired but you
decided you had to go for it if you were
going to win this game
yeah now of course it's easy to call
myself a hero but I mean I had an
advantage in before the game
my opponent needs to win much more than
I do I mean with the draw I would
qualify and I had this strategy I said
I'm going to play a normal game and if
draw happens then it's okay but and then
I got too excited
I thought that would rocket for probably
the game should be balanced but rook f7
looked kind of a move that might work
because it completely changes the
dynamics of the game and if you have
more time this can be very unpleasant
for them for your opponent so it's a
very risky decision but well as as I
already mentioned the champagne part I
had to do something because I do like
something yes well deserved how much did
you see you like all the way to Queens
c1 how much of the rest of the
possibilities you see or did you think
after Queen c1 I just have some chances
is crazy let's go for it I saw that I
definitely have some compensation I
didn't think that I was better or
anything but I thought he has nine
minutes and I have half an hour and the
position remains very sharp with with my
bishops pinning things so I thought it
was it was a practical decision
maybe not the good decision academically
but practically show your intuition just
that competitive intuition right at that
moment was very important and then
he could have kept the Fed name he
played a couple of off moves for example
bringing his King back to h8 along your
bishop in and then the rook d8 move your
eyes must have lit up when you saw Queen
e7 yeah yeah I felt that I'm out of
danger with my bishop 45 and King g3 and
then I thought that in the worst case
scenario probably will be a draw I'm not
risking any more that my bishop is
stupid
but then of course I was very lucky to
have that blunder that my opponent
committed through being the wrong
position my panel my colleagues
comparing it to the mortals look swans
in the past how do you feel about this
position it's such a beautiful one to
finish him off well of course it's very
pleasant to have a position where your
opponent cannot improve his position in
any way and yeah I'm very happy that
after all my sacrifice works so
beautifully so I mean as Larson always
said you know when you take risks you
will lose you will win but you will only
remember the wins
[Laughter]
yeah absolutely
and now you are tied for first after
winning in the first round
now you book ended it by needing to win
in the last round and you get a playoff
potentially it still makes stuff in the
mix tomorrow you must be excited
absolutely I think it's good to start
with a win and finish with a win but the
job is not yet done so I'm very happy
but you know when when you're lucky you
get hungry for more
well I will leave you with those wise
words and give you a chance to rest and
watch the rest of this like we are
congratulations on really masterful
effort thank you